But as you think about
setting yourself up for success
from a talent perspective,
from a people perspective,
because as we all know,
it's the people that make a business.
When you're an investor,
you always kind of invest
in the founder first. Right?
It's 18 B-idea
wins over a BT by idea any day.
Yael Kaufmann,
welcome to 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Thank you.
I'm doing well.
How about yourself?
It's great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
It's wonderful having you here.
I'm so excited to talk about
some different topics.
But we have to start
with a really extraordinary one.
How does a child
go to school seven days a week?
How does that happen?
Yeah.
That doesn't sound like
the common childhood
that I know of.
Yeah. I mean,
it wasn't certainly my entire childhood.
But it happened because
my parents are immigrants
from the former Soviet Union,
they're from the country, Georgia,
and they grew up speaking
all sorts of languages at home.
And so, for me,
I grew up in a household
that spoke Georgian, Russian,
Hebrew and English
pretty much interchangeably.
And for
a couple of years of elementary school,
I went to regular school in the US,
Monday through Friday.
And then on Saturdays,
I went to Russian school.
And on Sundays, I went to Hebrew school.
So, there was a lot of fun.
And education has been
a big part of my life.
A lifelong learner,
passionate about education.
And probably part of it is
because I went to school
for a couple of years,
seven days a week.
That's just [--]
So, do you speak both Russian,
i know you speak Hebrew as well,
but you also speak Russian?
Yeah. I do. I do.
Russian and Georgian, yup.
So, English, Russian,
Georgian and Hebrew.
That's just wonderful
and definitely sets you up
for a very interesting background.
But Yael, other than that,
you also went
to Harvard Business School.
You were an investor in VC,
chief of staff in the series-A company,
and now,
the co-founder and COO of Learn In.
Before we even dive into your journey
which I can't wait to hear about,
talk to me a little bit about
what upscaling is.
Set us up
for the second half of the process.
What is upscaling in general?
Yeah, absolutely.
I hear the term "upskilling it"
for around a lot.
And so, for me,
what I'll share is what I mean,
broadly speaking,
is the fact that a lot of times
when we talk about education,
to some extent we talk about
where you went to school.
If someone asked you about your health,
you wouldn't say that
I ran a marathon 13 years ago.
So, what were you learn in school
is really just sort of the beginning.
Right?
It doesn't end
or begin even really with a degree.
It's an entire lifelong journey.
And so, upskilling is kind of
the post school learning that you do
that's often on the job,
often on your own.
So for me, I had the flexibility
and the ability
to take two years off from the workforce
to go get my MBA.
But a lot of people don't.
And it's really, really hard
to find time to learn.
Time is actually
the biggest barrier to learning.
But upskilling is,
as we think about all of the things
that have changed
over the last five, 10, 15, 20 years,
of course, someone over
the course of their career
is going to learn more
over the course of the actual career,
then ingest
that formal beginning education part.
So, upskilling is everything
that goes into that
lifelong learning piece.
And that can apply to everything
from the small snack bites
that you learn from a one off-course
to longer form upskilling,
as I like to talk about it,
where it's a one off-courses
are not going to do it
for getting you the skills that you need
to succeed in the digital future.
Especially when the half life of skills
is decreasing as
the rate of technology advances
faster than ever before.
So, just as you are doing things
from investing to learning
to working, all at the same time,
the future world of working and learning
will all be kind of
more and more intertwined
as you talk about everything
from upskilling
to reskilling continuously
over the course of your life.
I think that's just fascinating.
And I can't wait to hear about
how you actually
help people and employers,
employees and employers
resolve the problem of upskilling
through learning.
But before that,
Yael, take me all the way back
to your journey.
Because it's not a conventional journey
by any means.
You are getting your MBA at Harvard
and which I'm sure
it's a phenomenal experience on its own.
But walk me through
a little bit of experiences.
And why go from MBA to investor
to chief of staff to co-founder?
Yeah. Well,
I'll start even before the MBA,
because we started even before
with my seven days a week of school.
So, I grew up with education being
a really important part of my life.
And I taught and tutored for a decade
in middle, high school, college
to make money.
And so, education has always been
a big, big part of my life.
But as I sort of went
into the professional world,
started my career as an investor
for some private equity
and then later in venture,
but had this idea for
how I was going to apply
all of my passion
for numbers and math
to the business world.
And then found that actually
a lot of what I enjoyed doing
was solving really hard problems.
And so, I found myself
more drawn towards the life
of an operator than that of an investor.
But really, really truly passionate
about helping people build businesses
across the entire kind of landscape.
And spend my two years at HBS,
very much at Harvard Business School,
very much focused on how I could help
mission driven entrepreneurs
and businesses thrive.
And so for me,
it's really important to be knowing
that I'm spending my time working
on something that's worthwhile,
that solving big problems.
And so, a lot of that is
sort of like mission driven in my mind.
But it can range from everything
from food to education to cybersecurity
and all of the ways that we talk about,
ways that we can solve
big problems in society.
For me, I was privileged enough
to be able to take the time
to go to business school,
but a lot of people don't.
And I encourage people to explore
what it is that they're passionate about
and make space
in their own professional journeys
to say, hey, I have a lot of people
doing a lot
of really cool things in my life,
what is it that I want to do,
what is it that
I am personally passionate about,
and where do I want to spend my time.
Because time
is your most valuable resource,
whether you're an entrepreneur
or an individual trying to make ends meet
and do everything across
the entire kind of lifelong journey
of learning and working.
Being really, really
thoughtful about that is important.
And so, for me,
I've been fortunate enough
to have those in my life
who I've considered
formal and informal mentors, advisors
who've been thought partners for me
as I've thought about
what journey I wanted to go on next.
And so, that's helped me navigate
the roads between early and late stage
investing and operating.
I've done it all
and I feel very fortunate
to now feel like I'm doing exactly
what I'm supposed to be doing
as an entrepreneur.
I think that's,
when we talk about Maslow's Pyramid,
which is something
that I've been thinking
ever since in my
my sixth grade Hebrew class,
my teacher showed us
the pyramid of Maslow
and talking about this
the enlightenment piece of the end
where everybody aspires to.
And I think that
what you're talking about here
is something
that really correlates to that.
This idea that
you can have your security,
you can have your job,
you can have your daily life,
but really, if you are aspiring
to have that personal fulfillment,
it's about also exploring
our real passions
and thinking how can we integrate them
into our work, into our daily life.
But talk to me a little bit about
this journey with Learn in.
And how do you
even think about before that even today,
you said something interesting
about the half life
of our knowledge and our skills,
that the half life is going down.
What's happening today
in the 21st century
and specifically starting in 2020,
why is the half life
of our skills going down?
Yeah. I mean,
there's a couple of things in there,
and I had to even
to parse out knowledge from skills.
Because as you think about it,
knowledge, something that you might learn
in a textbook or in an article
or something like that, that's great.
But how do you apply it to your life,
to your work
and being able to actually
continuously develop new skills,
learn new things, learning to learn
is a skill in it of itself.
And so, being able to do that
in a more and dynamic way,
more regularly, is something that
will set people up to succeed in life.
Because when you think about
the rapid pace of technology changing,
there's more data than ever before.
My undergrad,
I was interviewed the other day,
didn't have,
I was a math and finance major,
they now have a data science degree.
And that's something
that's happened in the last 10 years.
Right?
And data science,
when people talk about it,
we're just scratching
the surface of being able to understand
what we're talking about.
When people say data,
they can mean everything from,
you might need someone
who has a PhD in data science
or you might just need
to teach someone who's a business analyst
and is a wiz in Excel, Python sequel are.
Those are very very different skillsets,
very different profiles of candidates.
And you can learn different things
in different amounts of time.
Costs different amounts
in terms of dollars and time.
And so, being able to parse out
all those different things of
for both a business and an individual,
what is it that I'm trying to solve for,
what is it that I actually need to do.
And then be able to translate that into,
Okay, so I need
the skill set of data science,
data engineering,
data analytics, data literacy.
I need to just teach people
what does that mean, data?
Like how do we think about
all these different moving pieces
in a way that sets us up for success
as a business.
And individuals, they can see like
these are the areas
that are adjacent to my skill set.
Right?
If you are a software engineer that is
focused more on legacy languages
and want to upskill
into more modern frameworks,
you can do that in a way that is
sets you up for success
and set your business up for success.
And so, as we think
about all the different things
that are changing, right,
the ability to teach yourself
those new skills
and to be able to acquire
that knowledge on a regular basis
and then apply it to what you're doing,
is going to be
increasingly more important,
particularly as that rapid pace of change
continues to increase.
100%.
So, how you know, starting with the pain
and the problems in it,
because I'm convinced. I mean,
the world is changing rapidly.
The things that I thought
that are crucial in 2017,
they are so different in 2020.
And already,
when I'm thinking about
the start of that,
I'll hopefully create, you know,
in eight, nine months,
everybody's asking me, "Michael,
what's your startup going to be?"
And I'm like, I have no idea because
the world is going to change threefold
by the time that I'm going to have
to think of an idea.
So given that,
why is it so difficult for people
to do that now?
Why do we need something like
Learn In, from the get go?
Yeah. I mean,
I'd say that there's a couple
of different slices of the market
that have different pain points.
And so, a lot of where
we spend our time is in
the late stage enterprise sector
of the market.
And so, startups
that are constantly hiring
and constantly to acquire
these new skills
and apply them day zero, right,
day negative one,
those are very kind
of different types of situations.
But late stage companies,
large companies that also have
these really entrenched needs
but aren't necessarily able to,
perhaps hire the top talent,
the top of their class from Stanford
or wherever, they still have a need
to fill those business objectives.
And they have internal domain expertise
of individuals who have worked
in their companies for 10, 20, 30 years
and have the ability to learn.
And it's just about putting
those pieces together.
And so, to some extent,
it's about helping companies understand,
hey, you know,
firing and hiring people
is expensive and it's inefficient.
And the zero-sum war for talent
is not going to be sustainable.
And so, as companies are coming,
kind of coming out of this pandemic,
trying to think about
how they can hit the ground running,
yes, there's a lot
of stemming the bleeding right now
with a lot of the business world
being turned on its head.
And there are all these
kind of massive problems.
But as you think about
setting yourself up
for success from a talent perspective,
from a people perspective,
because as we all know
it's the people that make a business,
when you're an investor
you always kind of invest
in the founder first. Right?
It's A team B idea wins over
B team A idea, any day.
And so being able to do those things
that we'll be able
to set you up for success in the long run
is something that is very, very important
for companies of all stages
to be able to do.
And so, for late stage companies,
to some extent,
it's really just about equipping them
with the tools that they need.
And so, that's why
we've built features over, I mean,
hundreds of discovery calls
and with all sorts of folks from L&D,
learning and development teams
to various teams within HR
and people organizations
being able to say, hey,
what are your biggest pain points
and how do we solve them.
Well, you can actually create
a business case
for almost inevitably upskilling someone
in your organization.
Investing in your workforce
is almost inevitably ROI positive,
but especially in areas
for some of these digital skills, right,
when we talk about data,
when we talk about digital marketing,
any number of these things.
And so,
it's about helping people understand
that this is a need
that they can fill internally
by being able to invest
in these specific targeted
groups of individuals
to put them through
these various upskilling programs
that are outcomes oriented,
built for the modern workforce
that are remote, online.
Very much focused on skills
that are useful today.
And then be able to apply those
and see the benefit of that as a business
rather than needing
to hire people externally all the time
and not necessarily reap the benefits
of a really great workforce.
So, what I'm hearing is that
I think that I even came
with the misconception
that I was thinking, well, you know,
if you're a startup
and you need a skill,
just hire for that skill.
Tap into the pool of new graduates.
But I think that
what you're talking about here is that
you have a range
of these large late stage enterprises
that are perhaps, you know,
quite a few years old
and they have quite
a few number of employees.
And you know, the turnaround there
is not that quick.
And you have people that have more than
maybe for 10, 15 years
on a certain skill
and they need to upskill
to be more relevant.
And to me, that makes perfect sense.
You know, this company might not have
that quick turnaround
and that competitive edge
to hire that next top talent,
but they have this incredible pool
of very dedicated people
that are already working for them.
And if they can devote resources
through a program like Learn In,
they can upskill them to fit that,
to fit their new digital needs of 2020.
Is that about
what you're saying here?
Absolutely.
And so, there's all
sorts of organizations
like the AT&T Workforce 2020 initiative,
famously put a billion dollars
to work upskilling the organization.
Verizon, similarly,
has had these large budgets.
And so, when you think about it?
AT&T and Verizon,
they're putting a billion dollars to work,
not out of the goodness of their heart,
but because it's the right thing to do
for their business.
Right?
It's almost inevitably ROI positive.
And so, offering education as a benefit
is one thing that's become
more and more kind of popular mainstream
in these days.
And to some extent, yes,
that's absolutely an ROI there, right?
Attracting and retaining top talent
is fantastic.
And that is definitely where a lot
of the kind of dialogue has been.
But you can even supercharge it
that much more.
When you think about all
of the different organizations,
within HR works with, I mean,
when you have tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands
of employees globally,
there are inevitably
going to be inefficiencies.
And so,
when you can streamline those things
and you can take spend,
that's already happening
and make it more efficient.
Right?
Tuition assistance is something
that's been around since
for the last 40 years or so.
And it's in the US
around the $5,250 mark.
And that's because five grand got
went a lot farther in higher ed
in the 80s, right, versus today.
And today,
we're in a world where a lot of,
you know, changes happen.
And so, it's not just universities.
There's online certificates, bootcamps,
all these kind of new age types
of upskilling programs.
There's all sorts of different things
you can do to dynamically upscale
your workforce in a way
that is highly, highly aligned
to your business outcomes and objectives.
And you can do it in a way
using existing budget
that is more efficient and effective.
I have to say
that I had this phenomenal experience
with the graduate class at Stanford.
It was a product management course
taught by professor, Edison Tse.
We formed a team.
We were five working with Target
on helping them think through
some interesting use cases
using deep learning for their retail.
And one of the fascinating things
about it was that
I was the only Stanford student there.
The rest were Google, Amazon,
and we had Salesforce.
These were workers that came in.
And now, it makes perfect sense.
And I was thinking to myself, like,
how can I be
the only Stanford student here.
And it makes perfect sense because
they had a fantastic time.
They took that learning
back to the company,
the company became them.
And one other thing that you said
that's fascinating to me was
this idea of learning as a benefit.
Today, when you go to a company,
we ask for what's our compensation,
what's our dental,
our health care and [--],
and now we're introducing this
what's our learning.
Right?
What is that learning as the benefit
as another way of compensating,
which I think is just phenomenal.
That's so interesting.
Absolutely.
By the way, we're hiring.
If you ever want to come work for us
instead of doing your own thing.
Because you're doing
a phenomenal job pitching.
Wonderful.
So, tell me a little bit about
why you're so passionate about this.
I mean, I'm getting excited because
it makes sense to me
that you have this incredible workforce
that we need
to dynamically upskill all the time.
But why leave such incredible positions
that you've had,
started a new company
and why you do that?
Because, you know,
people say entrepreneurs are crazy,
so, why are you crazy?
I'm crazy for all sorts of reasons.
I'm personally passionate about
a lot of different things,
solving big problems as I mentioned.
For me, a lot of what
I've had guide my decisions
at various points in time,
has been essentially taking stuck
where I'm at
and where it is that I want to be,
and what it is that I'm getting out
of my current role,
and what it is
that I want out of my life and my career.
And so, one thing
that I'm really passionate about
is helping people find meaning
in their careers,
find the right paths for them.
I'm the go to person for a lot of people,
and trying to figure out
what they should do
with their life career wise.
And I'm also someone
who has known that my,
some of my most fulfilling roles
in time has been as a math tutor,
as a Hebrew teacher.
I loved teaching and tutoring.
I never thought that
I would do that professionally
and have a ton of respect
for those who do.
But it's one of those things
that there are very few things
that are as fulfilling as helping someone
reach their potential
or get closer to that.
Or help them learn something
or find some sort of meaning
or something like that.
And so that's something that's
always been really, really driving me
from a personal perspective.
I mentioned that education
is a big part of my life.
My mom is a math professor
at the University of Tel Aviv
for 13 years.
She's got a PhD in math.
Mathematician. She's brilliant.
As I think about education,
the people who have instilled in me
the value of education have been those
that have never stopped learning.
There are people who,
she still every once in a while
will sign up for an edX course.
And so, there's people with
where lifelong learning is just part
of their innate being.
And I feel very blessed to have
that ingrained in me from a young age.
And so, as I think about
the different moves
that I've had in my career,
I've had a lot of guiding forces, voices.
But a lot of people don't have that.
A lot of people don't know
what's available to them.
And a lot of people don't know
have a desire to learn, but don't know
what would be valuable to them.
And so, the individual learning journey
is something
that I'm really, really passionate about.
And then when you think
about some of the parts
of he traditional higher ed landscape,
particularly the US,
there's a lot of kind of moving pieces
that have not been so great
for the industry.
And there is a massive
student debt crisis
that is something that I also care
deeply about and would love
to solve in all sorts of ways.
There's a lot of really smart people
working on a lot of
really tough problems in that space.
For me, the slice of the market
that I'm really focused on helping solve
is the people who are working,
the people who are hustling,
the people who are employed
by their employer
and have a desire to upskill themselves.
Who want to learn,
who want to advance their careers.
Those are the people
that I want to support
on their lifelong journey.
And there are people,
who the companies
almost inevitably will want to invest in.
Because that talent is then
more loyal to your company.
They will want to stay.
They will feel more fulfilled.
You will get that skill set as a company
and not have to onboard a new person
and all these different things.
And there is a way
to kind of create all these synergies
by putting together
these different pieces.
And I just really, really love being able
to solve problems
and help people on their journeys.
In terms of what that's meant
for my personal kind of path making,
at different points in time
I've had people
kind of recommend different things.
So, my first move, for instance,
I went from private equity
to a portfolio company
of the fund I was at.
I had a couple folks
who were mentors for me say,
I think you'd be good at operating.
I think it'd be good for you.
You should give it a shot.
And I trusted their wisdom
and they were right.
And so, at some point
I went from thinking business school
was going to be not a good use
of my time or money to thinking,
you know, this is actually
the perfect thing for me right now.
And so, I think keeping an open mind
and having different people
have share their life experiences
and share their insights and wisdom
has really helped me.
When I was in Venture, I was thinking,
if I want to invest in series A companies
I should probably go work
on a series A company.
And so, that's sort of what led me
to move from that
to a chief of staff role.
And the chief of staff role
was a phenomenal learning experience
and a lot of opportunities
to get my hands dirty
in operations, partnerships,
the areas that I lead for Learn In now.
But then beyond that,
kind of understand what it's like to see
that the landscape from the back seat
of what a CEO does and see,
these are all the different moving pieces
that happen.
This is how decisions
are made in real time.
And these are the ways
that you actually have to
kind of make tough decisions,
which is really at the end of the day,
what operating is about.
Right?
You work with imperfect information
to make decisions
to the best of your ability
and surround yourself with people
who are ideally smarter than you
and amazing humans where you can
kind of have a group of people
who are from diverse backgrounds
because that will almost inevitably
make your decision
that much more well informed.
And be able to do so in a way
that drives everyone
together in a mission
that is hopefully making the world
a better place.
Yael, that was wonderful.
Toda raba. Thank you so, so much.
This was just incredible.
The most difficult
and important question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
I would have to say tenacious
is one of them.
Passionate is probably another.
And the last is that,
let's just go with positive.
So, I'm optimistic.
I love that.
I love it.
Yael, thank you very, very much.
Best of luck with Learn In.
Thank you. Toda raba.
Continue working in a positive impact.
This is just wonderful.
Thank you.
Thank you. Wonderful.
Thank you. Really appreciate it.